hey kyle you're on the air in illinois
hey howard i love the bat out of hell
talk yesterday i think that's one of my
favorite albums of all time i was just
curious like if you had to think about
it what are your three go-to albums of
all time well first of all like a gary
question does it all a disk
gary's are ridiculous like steely dan
i'm like you're gonna bring a steely dan
album do you only have 10 albums on a
desert island bad out of hell i was
actually listening to some meatloaf last
night remembering the dude the hits were
great not the entire album so you're
saying what are the three best albums
where the every song is [ __ ] killer
like you go oh my god there's not a bad
song on here and you can listen to the
whole album over and over again and love
it every time if you were gonna pick
number one it would have to be a beatles
album and it's either sergeant pepper's
or revolver like i'm talking about every
song is mind-blowing i'd probably say
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
band is number one and then
the other album that comes to mind what
i'm saying every song blows your [ __ ]
doors off
uh the second led zeppelin album you
know with heartbreaker into living love
and made like he could almost recite the
entire album every song is [ __ ] great
like if i put that whole album on we
it's mesmerizing it's like oh my god
every song is great there's not a
clunker in the [ __ ] collection if i
gotta pick a third if i'm gonna do
zeppelin the beatles i'd have to even
consider who would you consider jimi
hendrix experience because
every song
is mind-blowing even that what is it the
third stone from the sun or whatever
even that's a little trippy but it's
every [ __ ] song people would put
beach boys pet sounds on there but
that's [ __ ] uh look look
you know there are musicians who bow to
the beach boys but that's like a
musician thing not a i don't care people
listening thing no
you take it i'm i was a professional
disc jockey i worked at some of the
greatest radio stations well some of the
shittiest radio stations that we made
really yes yeah and uh and i'm telling
you i know what i'm talking about here
beach boys are not in the top three so
i'm gonna go with the the beatles either
revolver and sergeant pepper zeppelin ii
you can't keep equivocating you gotta
pick
okay okay jesus no you're saying either
this is getting into it when are we
coming back third round she's like a
school teacher over there
don't give me your [ __ ] essay give
me the answer
well i'm thinking out loud come on i
gotta hold it i'm being interrupted by
gary audiobook what do you want to say
gary so these are 10 records that if i
had to go to a desert island i could
only bring them with me what would i
bring well no surprises here you know
i'm a huge bruce springsteen fan so i
would definitely no we don't want to run
it's my favorite of all his records and
it was just a time and place in my life
where i could just go from the beginning
to the end and love every song oh spare
me
dan
i really love that band that i really
asia is still here
in new york get tough [ __ ] off my phone
with that list but i love that it was a
time and place in his life that he could
listen to every song and we all uh know
that he loves you all no yes he thinks
he thinks he's the star he thinks it's
the gary dalibati show
as you all know i'm bruce springsteen
fan well who knows beside your family
who are you no
yeah like
oh he's so taken with himself
as you all know i'm a fan of bruce
springsteen it's no secret
no surprise
as you all know i'm a size 38
as you all know what a pompous thing to
put in his book
as you all know that's like if like
david letterman's producer wrote a book
and as you all know i'm a bruce
springsteen fan and i enjoy pickleball
that's my new hobby pickleball i love
scotch but not the pity ones you know
that yeah
as you all know i went to a delphi
university
no surprises here no gary they're all
surprises
[Laughter]
all right let me get back to this
question of kyle's here it is sergeant
pepper zeppelin toe and i'm going to say
jimi hendrix experience okay well i
appreciate that if i can offer anyone up
to you to think about it would be
boston's first album i think everything
on that no oh it's a great outfit on the
radio
you're gonna put that in the top three
albums of all time
you're talking about your top three is
boston get off the phone kyle what are
you doing over here
get out of here hey well gary i'm so
sorry i just turned back on you yeah
yeah gary [ __ ] the whole thing up as
you know